if you're still playing miitomo
Nintendo's cute but ultimately limited
mobile social game you'll be glad to
know that an upcoming update will add
even more to the app I'm Kate and this
is your GameSpot news update Nintendo
has detailed an update for miitomo its
social networking app for mobile devices
the changes being introduced will allow
users to add friends in new ways among
other things according to a message sent
to miitomo users through the app the
update is coming soon the update will
allow users to send friend requests to
people who don't already use social
media services answer questions that
others have already answered Editor me
photo from the comment section and
experience improved startup and recovery
speed Nintendo announced on April 27th
that miitomo surpassed 10 million
downloads up from three million earlier
that month additionally the company says
those users have created more than 20
million me photos Nintendo has not
shared any details on how much money the
game is bringing in with its various
micro transactions
although miitomo is free players can
spend real-world money to speed up their
progress in unlocking new items what did
you think of miitomo
do you think this update will fix its
problems or is it ultimately not enough
to keep you coming back let me know in
the comments or come and find me on
twitter i'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it GameSpot